[Music]
targeting climate action is out of reach
for most and we identified three main
problems people don't have time
money or know how to take action so we
came up with trial a free mobile and
easy way to have an impact every day
directly from your phone if users choose
a location across the world where they
want to plan their treatment watch a one
minute ad from our sustainable brand
partners will then fund the planting of
that tree and that's it
we need to help the world's forests
today
all our sites are overseen by experts in
tropical forestry who help with our due
diligence process as well with the
monitoring of every site my advice to
anyone who wants to make an impact would
be
to start thinking about the impact that
the choices
have on the environment
then you can start your journey by
making
changes that you're comfortable with
whether it is paying attention to labels
before you make a purchase
or
attending protests
and each of these things will help raise
awareness create sustainable economies
and shape policies
[Music]